hello and welcome back to the shaky
sideshow in today's video we're going to
look at the question what are the
integrative hallmarks of aging so for
the past week videos now we've been
looking at the different hallmarks of
aging as given by this review article
we've looked at the primary causes of
Aging we've looked at the antagonist at
core marks or the responses to aging and
in this video we'll look at the systemic
core marks other way too far to as the
integrative hallmarks of aging so the
systemic core max aging includes
intercellular signaling such as
information and loss of stem cells so
what actually are the integrative
hallmarks so the integrator for marks
are pretty much two results the previous
two categories so they are responsible
for the decline in function and they
alter tissue homeostasis and function so
the key point of these hallmarks is to
show that aging doesn't just occur on a
cellular level but on the cell
non-autonomous level ie interactions
between different cells and tissues so
first up is altered into cellular
communication so organisms like
ourselves are multicellular and
therefore cells have to communicate with
other cell types such as when there's
damage in a tissue and this is important
for maintaining tissue integrity however
as you age this communication declines
and function and therefore contributes
the aging process so how do cells
communicate with each other so there are
kind of three different types of
intercellular communication you have
endocrine neuroendocrine and neuronal
signaling so an example of near a
hormonal signaling includes the insulin
igf-1 signaling axis which we looked at
before in nutrients Ed Malone but kind
of a hot topic in terms of intracellular
signaling at the moment and aging is
information and the increase of
inflammatory responses during the aging
process so this increase in inflammatory
reactions during aging has been given
the more fun name inflammation and so
inflammation can arise from many
different causes so one of them is
increased tissue damage that can secrete
pro-inflammatory factors secondly it can
increase due to the reduced ability of
the immune system
to detect the effects of cells or cells
have been infected by pathogens also
cellular senescence part of its
phenotype thus asked as we spoke about
last time is to secrete pro-inflammatory
factors and largely as you age there has
also been an Associated increased level
of pro-inflammatory factors such as TNF
alpha interleukin-1 beta interleukin 6
and NF kappa-b
and these are all inflammatory
transcription factors
so as given by the trophy at school
the best definition of information is
the long-term result of the chronic
stimulation of the innate immune system
which gets the fective on Aging but what
actually increases the production of
pro-inflammatory factors how does this
actually relate to aging so as suggested
by one of the figures and there's a few
art school there are six kind of reasons
for the production of pro-inflammatory
factors for SLE firstly is the increase
of dysfunctional organelles
predominantly the mitochondria secondly
there as you age is a defective disposal
of dysfunctional organelles this is
partly due to decreased Auto Fujii
thirdly there is an increase in the
endoplasmic reticulum the ER stressed in
a Cell also fourth there is activation
of the inflammasome fifth there is
defective protein stasis and lastly
there is activation of the DNA damage
response so the last two are the
proteases and the DNA damage response
increase are both linked to the primary
causes of aging as we discussed in a
previous video so yeah if we're going to
link into cellular signaling to aging we
need to really understand what causes
these factors to cause an increase
production Pro inflammatory factors
complicated but the key thing to
remember about these different hallmarks
of aging is that they're all
interconnected and actually we can
understand the causes of intracellular
signaling this regulation through the
other hallmarks and so this nature a few
article demonstrates well in this figure
how these different hallmarks that they
refer to as the pillars can be
interconnected with information
increased during aging and so evidence
for the importance of information in
aging can be seen by the age associated
diseases where information has been also
correlated citizen seen in obesity type
2 diabetes and atherosclerosis so the
last hallmark to discuss is loss of stem
cells so what is them cells so stem
cells are cells that have the ability to
replicate and regenerates itself a
time continuously but they also have the
potential to differentiate and turn into
somatic cell types or specialized cell
types such as a stem cell
differentiating into a skin cell and so
this is really important for the repair
and replacements of tissues that get
damaged during everyday life and so loss
of stem cells results in a loss of
repair and replacement and this
contributes to aging so how do some
cells get lost and what is the cause of
this loss of stem cells so in terms of
the causes this can be split into either
extrinsic or intrinsic factors so stem
cells are found in so-called stem cell
niches kind of like their home and the
NICHD
itself could get damaged during the
aging process and therefore the
protection of the stem cells gets lost
alternatively the stem cell itself could
become defective through certain
processes that we've already looked at
before
for example the shortening of telomeres
at the time can result in a lot of
replicate potential of the stem cells
but other primary causes of aging such
as DNA damage and loss appreciate thisis
can also result in loss of stem cell
function so this figure tries to bring
all the different hallmarks that we have
discussed together so in this video we
have looked specifically at the
integrator for marks so this includes
the loss of stem cells and perturbed
into cellular signaling and so as can be
seen both the loss of the replacement
and repair of tissues and the increased
information can be results in an
increase or acceleration of the aging
process due to the increased production
of protein lipid or DNA damage or the
loss of repair of this damage so for
more information on this topic if you're
interested in I highly recommend
checking out those for a few article but
hopefully this video has introduced you
to the integrative hallmarks of Aging